hi everyone we're back it's been two
weeks since Resident Evil zero the
episode the first one I've been
travelling you've been I don't know what
you ever do I'd do anything you went to
Paris I know I was in New York seeing
family and then Paris for work fare
mm-hmm it was fun I liked it I got a
cold toward the end but that was about
it as resident Knievel if you're new to
it we played through all the Resident
Evil games I'm strong getting era can
you believe we're playing all of them
and we're on zero I'm still getting over
said cold if I sound that job stuffy
let's jump in I don't know where we are
so yeah we got a little state first
anyway that's okay we're back in our old
studio as well so it's a homecoming of
dual significance yeah I like this new
mics everything's new we last thing we
did I think we're bringing that sharp
object to Rebecca to get her out of that
kitchen people had plenty of tips which
I'll load up the main one was that I
don't know why we thought we had to drop
stuff in the room where we would use it
you can drop items anywhere zero let me
pull up comments
these are 97 accurate one load game in
the cabin yeah there's not multiple I'm
a multi saver you know that that makes
me suspicious
load it up if it's wrong we'll restart
the recording continue yep
I remember I
this is where we stopped yeah cuz I
remember I was oh right that's my quick
switch yeah you're trying to bring her
that sharp thing that you got that I
said and I do it no we're on the way and
then ran into that look a scorpion thing
the crab crab yeah same thing for
crustaceans hey Arno forgot they were in
there scorpions insects have six legs I
don't know so I used all of my shotgun
yeah I do remember someone saying to me
you don't have to leave them in save
rooms you just leave items like anywhere
yeah and the reason that they didn't let
us stop because they didn't want us to
like leave like 10 things in one room
because then you can accidentally like
yeah this is our 98th episode we've not
next week but the following will be our
hundredth our centennial that's a big
deal so I want to leave this ink ribbon
here right cuz I don't need it yeah cuz
I saved mm-hmm
no there's these inky ribs here and then
I'm gonna go give her that thing thanks
oh yeah works for me okay lemme maybe I
should have my knife out I forget
where I'm going I want to go to the I'm
gonna turn your microphone off if you
keep eating into it come in where's the
dumbwaiter oh yeah also one thing I want
to address that we so remember we
started the game and then we're like oh
that's the wrong aspect ratio will have
to restart it and we didn't watch the
intro cutscene people didn't like that I
don't know if you remember but we
started the game and then we're like oh
[ __ ] we should change their aspect ratio
and then we found out we could do it in
game but we forgot that we'd skip the
cutscene anyway to try to get out faster
so know how to fix that cuz we've
already started right we don't know
next I go the wrong way next week or
maybe at the end of this episode I will
replay that cutscene so you can watch it
and have a better idea what's going on
okay sorry everybody I completely
understand why you would want to watch
that that upsets me too because now I
don't really think I know what's going
on we're bog am I going all the time
you're going the wrong way right now oh
wait yes yes Nona you're doing your this
I see you went upstairs do you want to
go I want to go to the dumbwaiter and I
want to put this wait I don't have it
yeah didn't I already did I give it to
her pressure yeah check her inventory
wait nobody has it wasn't I supposed to
give her an ice pick or some [ __ ] yeah
go upstairs maybe we didn't see did I
give it to her and she just hasn't
gotten it yet
I might be in the dumbwaiter yeah I
don't know there you go this is what
happens yeah I'm gonna hope if enough of
us complain about the skipped intro we
get to watch it your your wish will come
true Rob Butler you win this round Rob
Butler mm-hmm
also another important mechanic system
if you will is that everything happens
in real time so if you leave Billy in a
fight by switching to her Becca he's
still gonna be in that fight right but
does he like do better when he's a I so
a I can fight but if he dies it it's you
restart restart the game or restart the
save safe I'm gonna [ __ ] this is there's
a man on fire all right get the [ __ ] out
of this corner snake 89 wait something's
on YouTube is a claim there is eros I
saw a bunch of people saying they're
playing through resin evil zero lives
with us that's fun
what was that noise him why is he
he grew cuz he's on fire in a zombie
make sense why they skip the intro
cutscene lamps max let's try that again
I don't know why all my button
configurations are
get on the ground stop drop and roll
people suggested swapping their handguns
as well so Rebecca gets the more
powerful one that makes sense because
whoa she take less damage that makes
sense she is hurt too already which is a
bummer I didn't have a great start to
this game yeah
triple-a triple-a is also playing the
game with us need to kill them could I
have just not killed them three three
days ago
buck-buck oven said where the [ __ ] is my
new installment of Kamini
where's Micah Nene we're back girl oh
wait wait actually what God thank God
for these new mics reload he's gonna get
you oh my god
let's try it again wait where are you
pointing you dumbass [ __ ] alright
alright alright that didn't
[Music]
this game looks really good I can't
believe I just got hit again that can't
be good whoo I'm endangered Falls Jerri
98 did you guys really just skip the
intro and forgot about it shaking my
head I blame you it's fine
nothing sucks
all right
I hope nobody else wakes up I think
somebody woke up somebody welcome I need
um hey buddy
Bell so does he follow me now how does
this work
do we like talk about it um yeah I'm
trying to think were you even going now
why'd you come back this way I just
wanted to see him
oh um didn't she have something you're
looking for the captain's key or
something I think um keep coming toward
the camera but will he come with me
where does he just stand there is there
like a whistle button you press Start
got it
[Music]
right so we need this key do I have it
no does he have it no did we drop it
because we ran out of items when I was
killing the crab boss that was upstairs
I could go upstairs
hmm yeah you could I don't think he
dropped anything up there did you work
well I left
oh I'm him now I left a lot of things up
there okay
like there was a [ __ ] ton of items up
there
and I couldn't take them all remember
mm-hmm where's upstairs that's back this
way I thought wow nevermind so like
through here again right is that what we
learned just now yeah okay and then I'm
gonna kill this man mm-hmm and protect
Bucca
oh he's shooting like through my body oh
my god I'm out of she's got you have
seven shotgun shells but put your knife
out and kill shootin come at me go oh
man what a duo best duo ever I say
come get some get it girl I worked out
she needs health she has health doesn't
she she has one green but I'd like to
combine it with a red okay those stairs
looked oddly not as good that's a
greenie
there's a green herb that is a good a
nurse why didn't you pick that up last
time I mean cuz I was running out of
speed we where's the rest of the
upstairs there's another stairway
farther but you can get the screener
right now alright it's not red I'm
looking for a red because I want to
fully upgrade herd so we gotta go all
the way back to the other stairs it's
not that far
it's not but yeah farther by the way
girl
I feel like I wasn't doing enough I felt
like she was shooting and I was like
poking the air I hope she doesn't die I
think it'd be fine I would feel bad
because when she's a I she's my
responsibility but not when you're
controlling her no she's a backup here
what's through that door zombie
oh this is where she was duck god I
really got turned around
alright I think we're back now I think
we know what's going on mm-hmm
I forget our goals but I remember like
this is where I defeated the crab I
think right know that was back up the
other stairs where's the room with all
the items uh I got the emergency window
right there it was here I don't know
excuse that but I don't remember this
being what we were doing my what room
were the items there was a room that has
like 20 items right before I killed the
crab no that hallway got like covered
with that slimy stuff so I can't get any
of those items you will eventually stop
let's let's just embrace the [ __ ] I
got a red herb in there I think cuz like
I don't need to be in here hmm
so that means all I can do is give her a
green herb which isn't like what I
wanted I wanted to give her those items
let's go back to the captain's cabin
toward the other end well we need the
captain's no I know but there's a cabin
with like uh she has a lockpick and
Billy didn't so I thought maybe we had
to get her out and go use her lockpick
[Music]
have you been to Paris no I've never
been to Paris yeah I like it
I've never been like anywhere in Europe
except for Germany Gamescom uh-uh no
verts burg girlfriend just
was from there she um shut off sir I'm
listening I'm just I know I want you to
do both she traveled abroad in America
and that's when we became friends and
she's like if you ever want to go her
name is Evelyn listen don't continue
name's Evelyn she's awesome
she's like if you're ever in Germany you
can stay with me and that was like I'm
buying my tickets now [ __ ] she let me
say you're one of those people yeah
don't tell me I can stay with you for
what it's worth I never ever have a
couch or anything you can stay on okay
stay away from me and anybody away from
my girl
don't touch my girl you looking at my
girl that's what I assumed tough men are
like so one of the comments that his
tattoo says mother love no way hold up
the knife I mean it's supposed to be
tribal but it totally says mother love
it does look yeah look at it says mother
love that is so dumb that's so [ __ ]
sick he gets a cooler every doesn't that
way you were tattoo says yes no mine
says mommy kisses
dad's got him Toshi right there no sorry
come back door right there yes this is
where we started the thingy mm-hmm we
started the episode no it's not um okay
cool so check this room
or go up the other of that ladder maybe
every way yeah what's up that letter god
I hope it's the room with the stuff in
it yeah there you go
one of the [ __ ] is half that's to open
the hatch on the other side of the train
but I think this is the room
this game looks really really good
oh this is this where I fought the crap
yeah wait go get that thing though I was
gonna get on the way back yeah we need a
noun
uh no you're right I think I'm pretty
sure about the other cuz I kind of want
my items that I can mix I don't want any
danger am i okay good
maybe this is the room this has got to
be the room I was like there was a room
with a bunch of items okay good
oh yeah see red or that's the gym that's
what I've been in first day it's dry oh
well she's the only one who can make
these these things mm-hmm so I come in
use it mm-hmm use it cuz I'm dying and
then I think is there another red hmm
no there's not that sucks first-aid
green herb what is that I don't know oh
is that the conductor's thing that you
can lockpick and get to yes you can
lockpick that I believe as Rebecca no
skip a little because ex I mean it looks
like it could fit a round object okay
interesting so her personal is his
personal is the lighter mm-hmm and he's
full he's got two nice no reload there's
no ghost I mean it's not gonna free up a
space but at least you'll reload the
shotgun okay
I think it's not right yeah yeah you
might as well give her the green herb oh
yeah sure you can't make Sun [ __ ] Mary
god bless it keeps hitting square uh do
I exchange is that what that means yeah
and she gives me nothing cool [ __ ]
Rebecca and then do I want to leave
these items in here um like what's that
maybe I'm gonna in cribben no I'd say
take them don't got it don't worry about
the ink ribbon you already got two next
to the typewriter downstairs okay so
yeah let's think through this because do
you you just your full health on both of
them mm-hmm I don't know what's coming
next so you could just take both of them
maybe he could take the first dates yeah
you need room for that uh that hook
thing in the other room I mean is there
anything in that closet no okay cool
he's almost full
she's got two slots he's got one slot so
we can't afford to so also the handgun
ammo is technically more valuable for
his gun Oh should I do the gun swap now
yeah I think so okay so I'm gonna she's
gonna take the shotgun is that your no
no no this handgun is better okay
is it the same bullets yeah that's what
I'm saying the bullets are more useful
for that handgun I believe also go to
her inventory is there a way you can
split up the handgun bullets as if
you're just sharing a few of them
exchanged yeah oh nice you can sweet
that's very helpful to know I don't know
give him 15 key to 15 20 25 when he
seems like a lot but again her gun is
more powerful okay
it's all she has I also lost a slot
doing that yeah for him yeah okay
I'm gonna have her take first-aid spray
cuz she can drop it yeah maybe she put
it on him
can she spray him I don't think so
like a resonable five I don't believe so
I could be wrong
let's wait until that one of them is
hurt to find out just so you know you
did mean to leave the green herb there
right mm-hmm I can't take it and pick up
this hook oh right unfortunately just
for posterity's sake can you make sure
you can't yeah go that way okay cool
right I can look at the map I'm pretty
sure you're going back toward the other
side of the Train to lift that thing in
the dumbwaiter room or the kitchen or
whatever oh my god yeah so annoying we
could have saved time by getting this
hook thing as Billy and then going to
meet up with her back we had to get our
bridges we acquainting ourselves [ __ ]
taking reunion to her he was like I
fought a crab here and she's like I
don't see it and he's like I swear it
was here I swear I was [ __ ] it was a
huge crab panel of her she's like
sheriff Ellie
a huge crowd
right yeah sure hmm
sure you were looking at your pubes ha
ha ha ha [ __ ] pubes I am extremely
tired today are you I'm not yawning but
I'm just like brimming with exhaustion
ok back this way and then the Train wait
how many Resident Evil 0 like experts do
you think we have we've lost because
we've been going back and forth across
the Train listen I don't think they
watch us for our expertise oh no I know
that we've got our regular friends that
like watching for whatever reason but if
you're here for perfect play get out go
over to my channel subscribe to Mike my
Hardy are you to say that probably not I
don't have no no I don't I mean it
doesn't matter I don't have like
gameplay stuff I just have my welcome
again spot don't forget to subscribe to
my personal channel my Marty I mean I
yeah good thing my boss doesn't watch
the show what if he does
I think upstairs I didn't mean that so
like literally if you subscribe to my
channel you would just get my GameSpot
video portfolio that's all I use it for
right now considering putting up X come
too if I get enough subscribers I might
start putting up X come to the wrong
place so if that sounds like something
gears you're interested in maybe go
subscribe to my channel I'm digging
myself deeper ok panel is somewhere
around here I thought it was to the
other side of the room hmm
or maybe it wasn't up the stairs maybe
was still downstairs
yeah so all sake for Pete's Packers
I think jetlag is catching up to me as
well I have no excuse that's my excuse
trash farming subscribers farming
subscribers that's that's Mike mah
giveaways and does yes they're here the
panels in here I knew there was a
kitchen okay wait why'd you leave him
let's go okay okay let's go
oh is this okay you're gonna start doing
something like this now I didn't know
game was that there you got panel give
her that panel over there and use that
where I was like come on come on come on
yes live where's the panel right next to
her this come on
there's like a manhole thing yeah what
she couldn't [ __ ] use her hand that's
stupid
she definitely could have done that
doors locked I'm assuming the freight
car door don't go in there yet
I'm just curious this or I'll turn that
off and off that's making me so anxious
this mm-hmm I can't turn the other one
doesn't seem to be anything of use
there's a ladle there that you could
have used for the same exact purpose all
right all right I'm going down oh oh
it's a pepper shaker did you what did
you throw as now the only thing we're
trying to do right now is open that
suitcase go in the crawlspace I'm
assuming Billy could not fit maybe oh no
he's pretty yeah [ __ ] Jack there yeah
fat you see Mac in the new Sonny uh
trailer he's actually like shredded now
he's like legitimately just stopped
short
I wish I'm Shh
what am i doing he's killing that dog
for starters nice nice
- Billy [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah I'm so into this [ __ ] knife
and dog oh look at him his mouth is
still over there's a lot of stuff down
here Billy okay
so help me God thank God I'm still fine
he's like yeah yeah babe like shut up
Billy you see my arm senses creeper you
know why cuz I love a lot of mothers oh
is that a shiny thing what's that uncle
owner that would work for the brief oh
this and this possibly the bin you need
another one
ah the gold ring fits perfectly in the
hole yeah okay well I'm gonna fix my
chair and others dogs not trying to kill
us
who's sat here before me very tall
person that's who according to the lower
thirds okay I have two free spots nice
well no I'm not trying to be cute like
should I get the gas oh I don't know
maybe you think I meant Oh Billy's here
he did fit through the crawl space wait
what's that I've already left
should we pull the lever and release the
lock yeah
hook shot what's next the Megaton hammer
the ocarina
they're really gonna force a puzzle like
this wait are they gonna make me switch
people and pick it up yeah
seems extremely unnecessary
switch humans
oh really
like a Batman kind of thing
you're mine now what came with a manual
that's nice
manual whoo this device should only be
used when inspecting difficult to access
car rubes or when connecting special
trains train is special returned to its
proper location at be used at the back
of the Train wait okay
there's a ladder outside the small
window by the first floor section door
on the third carriage got a [ __ ]
manual is this it's a very specific male
firing the device that hooks high onto
the ladder after using the winch to
climb using the winch to climb after
securing the hook and use the winch to
lift yourself up the unit can be damaged
lifting more than 80 kilograms that's
you belly you fat piece of [ __ ] so fat
okay so to the third carriage that that
our section of the third carriage what
check that stuff on the right oh I lost
Billy yeah yeah
oh I don't say anything when he's not in
the room you idiot
should get this gas or what you want it
no over there let's do the door that's
the door I unlocked dogs oh okay
so there's gas can in there and health
it's that one one yeah
shotgun shells too well should he take
the shotgun shells then yeah might as
well
and I can't carry anything else so I'm
done Z's or you could drop stuff I want
all this stuff the suitcase isn't it
like wait it's not what I meant
I want the shotgun shells
okay
I'll check it out Roger this way okay
it's nice that they have teamwork it's
good to see teamwork Oh
wait so
I said I'd leave her and she said yes
should I use a shotgun or should I eat
knife em knifing really yeah but I don't
wanted to get hurt
shotgun him I'm coming babe she backed
into the other room she's running she
ran away
not working maybe shotgun that's two
hits like a shotgun
[ __ ] get up
[ __ ] we're both hurt I [ __ ] up I did
really bad on that shut up oh my god how
am i endangered cuz he got you a lot
she's in caution like should I just quit
the game no the guy who really got you
good because I was using night
I'm so disappointed in myself he came
out of nowhere
get away from me it's embarrassing
you're not bad right yeah miss meadow
what is that wine what's it for I don't
know
what were we doing going back to the
third car first section open your map
there's a ladder somewhere I think it's
is it this
I don't remember
open I mean you can find that manual
again third car which cars the third car
from left to right this is the this is
the front two three okay so it's the one
with the stairs in it right yeah I guess
huh come with me if you want to live
I can't believe she got hurt and I
almost died
I haven't saved in a while not that
we've accomplished very much anyway
Jesus sorry there's more you keep you on
your toes so I think I think you're on
the right way but isn't this the third
car maybe upstairs oh no God did it say
go upstairs
No all right there yeah
hook shot but don't use don't now with
him what's the hook shot good thing he
picked up his Rebecca
Oh
somebody put a bunch of holes in this
train wait don't go in there app why not
cuz that one see else is up here
that's it okay going there
crap
Oh for [ __ ] sake that's like unfair
honestly and I have nine bullets there's
a knife at your feet - and this guns
powerful you'll kill him
yeah I think I have any space for that a
box oh my god what did I just do oh my
god
can they attack him right now that's
while I'm not him
yeah I don't but they're not near him
are they those were upstairs I thought
and you're upstairs now I can eat that
green herb and be and save a free slot
and then beyond fine sure I hope they're
afraid of rings and also remember you
could have just dropped the green herb -
you can drop anything you want I know
but I
hey maybe it's the conductors key is in
the lap oh it wasn't the suitcase isn't
that what he said that looks like the
Elder Scrolls online logo kind of
Ouroboros the ru Auto photos--
conductors key card [ __ ] yeah
what's his name what - hold on hold on
just kidding Jimmy Lewis dick okay cool
do you want to know anything else about
it no his name is Jimmy Lewis from the
ecliptic express his security number is
that be dope being conductor oh no I
don't want to leave this okay and I
still have one free space so I could
take this knife I don't know if I need
it but I'll take it as well I feel like
they gave it to me for a reason
mm-hmm so do it up [ __ ] she won't
maybe they gave us both knives cause
like that's the best way to kill the GU
Oh someone mentioned fire for the GU
comments yeah for the leech oh no that
was for the leech things okay so
don't be dude okay what was it
it's goo man mmm maybe the knife will be
good hopefully so oh you're right
outside this room now that's the room
with the ink ribbons and the great so do
I want to go down the stairs to meet
back up with Billy yeah but just for
experimentation see if the knife oh no
those are the leech things that's the
fire does she have a lighter no he does
it's on you I think I have a leech on me
I thought hello okay Oh Xavier Roy
Herrera apologies if I butchered that
can you open the menu quick I got a
little Easter egg thing to try as you
either one okay go to her personal item
yep yeah go switch you can change your
characters costume so do you use Oh
oh my god
that's not way with leather it's like a
de Waal oh my god Javier thank you so
much
I like the Stars one of the most still
but the cowboy boots are template I have
to see Billy's now remembers switch back
to her potion kit when you
Oh jacket what come on where's his
[ __ ] leather [ __ ] Yakuza kiwami
[ __ ]
hell yeah my god that's [ __ ] tight
switchbacks here lighter pieces now at
least you can't see his mother love
tattoo huh I feel like it's an upgrade
for both somehow just goddamn daisy
dukes she's it so much more risk for
infection thanks Javier Thanks
alright what am i doing
oh we have the keycard so we want to go
to the key card yes wait where was that
with that here
yeah far left yeah this is your new
installment of kidney buck ovens
what's wrong with Kamini no I'm just
saying those the count earlier there's
thing where's Kenny knee okay
I am trying and
[Music]
[Music]
the cowboy boots are very good yeah oh
that Trevor how was the t-virus leap it
is and why did it contaminate both the
lab and the mansion as well as a train
almost three miles away that's
irrelevant we must make sure no
knowledge of this gets out destroy the
Train completely how far away are you
from the nearest branch line
don't let that happen to you okay
wait should we go out there shouldn't
kill those mimic Ruiz with fire whenever
you can to breath invent them from
spawning leeches upon death I don't know
whattcha maybe the knife so let me ask
you this how do I use my fire no that's
so you that's it's not for those it's
for the dudes who dropped those what
you'll burn the bodies yeah later not
the leeches the leeches have already
spawned it's the things that spawned
leeches I'd think a knife will just help
with leeches okay so the leeches won't
attack me when we go out there probably
will okay and I don't know if the knife
will work I'm just hoping I don't feel
like it a little bit let's try
he's not that he's not that how do you
know I just know it can you go the other
way
ciao babe
it's [ __ ] Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid here you look so dumb
okay keep scaring myself
isn't this the way the leeches went feel
like you shouldn't follow leeches
you know like when birds are flying you
like go towards the birds cuz they know
where land is you always like run away
from releases if they're all going in a
certain direction you don't want to go
that way Woods Plan C the brake control
the following three steps are necessary
activating the controls brake controls
are located in the following locations
first car driver's compartment rear
that's where you are in a deck of the
fifth car to activate the system you
must insert the magnetic card into the
device in fifth in the fifth car this
will supply power to both sets of
controls
step two enter the code for the rear
deck unit to release the lock I don't
know what the code is that's what we'll
try to do enter the code to remove the
lock upon completion of these three
steps the manual brakes can be used
it seemed like a really efficient way to
like pick who stays behind [ __ ] ah
probably know I'm probably Rebecca
because she's weaker and then Billy
someone in the comments recommended
picking Rebecca but I don't know if they
mean leaving her behind or going as her
I I agree with you I would leave Rebecca
I think
I saw someone say that you don't want to
just constantly shoot the crab whatever
don't add up it's gonna be Rebecca
sure do it from here okay all right I
love you
what you look hot how does your radio
stay in your back pocket oh it's just
hanging out there's a timer go oh my god
we need the card that card get that card
tell me the timer doesn't go when I'm in
here I need the card yeah give her the
hand going around
she's got shotgun stuff you don't have
or drop the knife drop the knife got the
knife here oh wait if you leave this
here will you not be able to get up I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know you'll
do the brakes okay cool yeah now there's
there's handgun rounds to get the card I
don't have enough room I have to drop
something else you have handgun rounds
already don't you yeah
wait I don't have time for this yeah do
that
okay all right let's go where am I going
all the way the back what's the code
though I wonder I don't know does this
game autosave I don't know time oh wait
what if they attack her though when
you're gone I don't know I just keep
going
is it on the card maybe examine the card
[Music]
is it that number it's conductor room
he's press X on it like do you want to
like write these numbers down no if
that's not this is conductor room that's
not where you're going press X no let's
just get to the back I'll figure it out
oh my god I think this game does home
safe hopefully I've gone really far
Oh for [ __ ] sake you could say if
that's what saving right there right
there some caves fault I tried to juke
him
[Music]
- did you Kim
oh my god here's your there's four oh
you're doing what yeah shoot him shotgun
get the shotgun out do it
Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] I didn't think it was three all
right I got I kinda got eaten they're
very fun I mean I don't think so
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm in danger
still get hit
hey that's a star's member
I feel like I can't do head shots in
this one
[Music]
what am i [ __ ] doing alright you
going oh wait no what this is just gonna
lead you out to the hookshot area yeah
unless it's in here somewhere where am I
going
I don't know just you got time you got
something I do not have time hey do ok
back the fifth car one two three four
five right
one two three four yeah did I go too far
we got fun try going out to where the
hookshot is maybe that's it
that might it's blinking red so maybe
that's it just like me I'm dying
there's buttons all over the door
assuming one of those left yeah oh my
god
oh my god
you need to equal 36 but what sure stop
yelling you're not helping I'll be the
voice of reason as always okay
there's nine do 9 times 4 is 36
but there's 10 to them so 9 times do 3
keep doing three
keep going three three three three three
three not the last one
now do nine
I need something yeah whatever the
whatever is a there you go that's not
the only one that's Billy I've engaged
the control device for the break over
Roger I'll put the brake on now
what she's gonna do it too what do I do
do the same thing sixty seven so seven
seven seven seven seven right yeah 9
times 7 is 63 14 21 28 35 42 no no no 49
yes yes 56 63 64 no no six fifty six
plus seven I'll do five five five five
five five five do five you don't math
what [ __ ] 56 is before for four it's for
its for its for why are we start
[ __ ] math
[Music]
wow that's [ __ ] brutal wait we did it
right that's really brutal like they
make you do that they're tiny
do we die
game over
aisel suit wow that was quite the
[ __ ] ending to it the Train
for the record I had the solution here
and we did not use it because it's not
always the same thing
all right we got they're just stuck we
have to find a way out that got intense
oh she's got a knife equipped get it get
away from there you're really hurt still
as him
get away from that I'm [ __ ] not him
oh really we got through all that there
that's gonna be an autosave I'm assuming
oh my god did I just lose all that
progress it's a resonable 3 all over
again well now we know what to do right
[Music]
well let's get back at it but we can do
it all faster now that we know we're
doing si I switch to her get the ice
pick
drop the ink ribbons I'm gonna save like
once like a little bit more now that I
know that this is so [ __ ]
I feel so broken this game for doing
that right after you just survive right
there all right um okay no we can do
this much faster this time once you
unlock this with her you can go back to
Billy and get that hook thing shine like
this will take much faster watch install
the items I don't know but yeah that's
if I don't use them do I lose them
probably yeah cuz the train crashes yeah
um okay now I'll switch to him and go
get that hook thing and just come meet
her here wait wait wait wait is she in
danger yes although I don't know if you
would go down the stairs
yeah she seems fine okay so he's getting
the hook yeah okay where's the hook no
he and those other items so he could
drops oh yeah drink sorry
drop off the save ribs and Cribbins yeah
okay actually no no you don't you don't
have to go in here to drop them you can
drop in the hallway I can drop them
anywhere but I've already gone in yeah
but also you if you want to grab them on
the way back
also the knife I don't really think you
were using it that much at all anyway
and it's just taking up space
well that's stay on the train I wonder I
don't know I don't know I can't I'm like
not over one you're broken go I can't
believe that just happened
alright getting the hook yeah stay in
there that door it's in here up the
ladder
and I was trying to play as him because
I thought you were him that's why I like
Mary what are you doing I oh yeah
because you switched the Rebecca don't
hit the brakes also the red herb and
everything is in the roof passage I'm
gonna get the red herb that's worth
getting oh and you need the suitcase and
I know I'm out of space
[Music]
at least reload just for I know this
won't help but it's annoying me can use
reload your shotgun
and you are coming back here anyway with
Rebecca once you get you could leave the
suitcase and get that later when you
come back here when do I come back to
unlock the conductor room thing
oh yeah you'll literally drop down into
here as her oh then I but you do need
the UM I think it's worth taking one of
the herbs maybe the right word I would
take this the spray because she can take
the herbs and convince a need the
suitcase yet you'll find one ring as her
right but she can hold it right or no
yeah just take the first aid that's a
complicated game
no whammy no whammy no whammy got it
yeah all right so should I just switches
her no he needs them so he's gonna hook
the kitchen is that going to the kitchen
yeah to get in the crawlspace to get the
hook shot to come back and do all that
[ __ ] does he need her to do that or
should he just do it on his own
the hook shot can't support him oh he
can't get the hook shot without her bat
- okay so I'm gonna pick her up on the
way we're gonna go together mm-hmm is
that the idea
this is the first time in a while we've
got owned by a present evil Game three
was probably no I mean we died a fair
amount in five and all the games really
I was pretty I was pretty big bummer I
like didn't if I would have just
switched with triangle I could have
saved that scenario well we're learning
the game more anyway for doing this
again I mean I'd like to think that I
will do better next time
like I'll certainly you know what's
interesting that I did learn from that
scenario was like I was like [ __ ] like
I'm getting hurt but we didn't really
have a lot of time to do it differently
no you did mostly what you should oh my
god you're coming back you might as well
kill him now oh I know it wasn't it's
very much it was totally intentional
also based on a comment I don't know
that this guns more powerful but it's
got a higher critter eight oh [ __ ] I'm
out yeah
yeah wait for it wait for it wait for it
oh you decapitated that first guy good
Oh remember to get the shotgun shells
closer back to normal
[Music]
cuz you're the shotgun was useful for
the break thing yeah it was section I'm
like a little depressed cheer up you got
you know you going I can't believe that
oh my gosh suck it up okay
I wonder what that wine does now I'm
curious I know the wine what's up with
the wine
okay there's dogs down here so she's
also still hurt she's on caution does
she have a green herb no you left it on
the other side so she's got a green she
does yeah what yeah yeah you left the
green Ana read up on the top yeah I did
ah all right so she's got we okay so I
gave her the better gun and then and
then I'm gonna leave this screen again
I'm gonna exchange give him some yeah
he's good 30:20 seems good yeah and then
I missed it so that just brought you
back to caution you know what I'm not
feeling though is the is the clothes
they're wearing at the moment I can't
yeah yeah yeah now okay
Morales back up I don't know I kind of
like these these two outfits like both
showing a lot of skin Billy's got his
arms exposed his mother-in-law yeah this
is very good this is much better than
before his [ __ ] jockeys a thing
wasn't doing it
got on this thing and kill some dogs
babe here we go dogs dogs dogs dogs dogs
what happened to the Baha men the but it
was fun but it was jumping hey yo yo you
like did a backflip off of her fuel
though also yeah what's up with the fuel
Oh so that's one of the keys you need
for the suitcase right
definitely need to take that with one of
them shotgun shells take have Billy take
those so it doesn't take up any more
space like what's up with the fuel so
maybe you can come back on the train who
knows nice yeah yeah get that gold ring
get the green oh yeah he's super full
she's got lots of free space right now
actually wait
so I could take some of this stuff I'm
going to go to the fuel don't like pick
it up or whatever just and see if you
can expect inspect it oh yeah take that
- okay that was an accident but I will
take it like what am I doing with that
philosophy I'm really curious I mean I'm
gonna leave it there for now cuz I can't
you go do the hookshot
I can't get the gun oh you can combine
the gas tank with the wine to make a
Molotov cocktail
that's pretty cool we should do that
[Music]
that would be helpful to give to
how much space do I have okay I have to
do it now does the gun take up two
spaces no I think it does you're not
gonna be able to do the wine until you
get the hook shot because the zombie
won't pop out and open the fridge oh I
really don't think it's necessary
because I mean it might save shotgun
ammo and Billy if you give the Molotov
to Billy
Oh
wouldn't you need a cloth or something
though as well I'm right overthinking
this
you're definitely overthinking it
oh right I got it
after all this time
oh and also that's that would be the
fire that someone was mentioning about
fighting leeches so Molotov is probably
gonna be useful it does take up some
spots I I know I want told you that yeah
I must be able to get stuff on the so
now got the hook shots
no in the kitchen oh this door great
you're also already doing better than
back up dumbass
okay cool so I can use the gun to get up
there you're also coming back here as
Billy if that helps you could really
quick make him I'll top on the way back
okay because I was thinking like can I
give him she's gonna she's about to get
rid of the hookshot and the that gold
ring I didn't get the suitcase you left
you left to back up cuz she's going back
there anyway she drops back to the roof
it so we're gonna use the hookshot let's
go sorry I'm just looking at my options
here okay I'm thinking it through don't
worry I'm on the case go alone okay
let's regroup my key me [ __ ] he would
help okay so we're going this way yeah
and we're gonna use the hook shot in the
train window as Rebecca yes
god damnit they're more
it looks like I'm afraid and she's
protecting me okay look at those frayed
jeans shorts I thought they were called
daisy dukes actually I don't even know
[ __ ] Daisy Duke was that racist white
dude I don't know a lot about those baby
jeans good job I actually just want to
switch people and then I want to use me
my hooky I feel like this isn't an item
you should just throw away after you use
even though the game makes you yeah it
seems like they say specifically on the
manual to put it back you know you know
oh [ __ ] oh you still do have it so yeah
you should just drop out oh you're gonna
use anything unless you're seven I'm
gonna put it back huh such a tiny room
hey yo did I ever use my knife not as
her though oh right yeah I'm gonna drop
I'm gonna drop the hook
it seems like only yesterday I died oh
okay so that's helpful
what so items will carry over in the
next section if you at least inspect
them so when you say pick this up or no
so happy paws back so when you are about
to pick something up and it says use or
no and then you say no as long as you
interact with it light in that way it
will mark it on your map so as long as
you mark them on your map it will carry
over oh so I want to make sure to do
that yeah with everything so I want to
touch everything at least in the middle
east is in the room across the hall that
kind of makes this worth it I don't know
if I'm just saying that because I feel
bad but it's gonna be a long episode and
everyone's gonna be like they're gonna
see the time they're gonna be like wow
you got a lot done and I'm gonna be like
you stupid idiots also don't forget the
suitcase isn't that up here or is that
the other upstairs yeah upstairs you
didn't get the green herb you know I
picked it up and put it back down Oh
because yeah hey babe so now what I
could make a malt off no get this
suitcase okay where's the suitcase
oh they're upstairs as her or as him/her
right she has the keys yeah she's got
that u-boat you need both of them to
come come on the next thing you do is Oh
getting the card out of the suitcase and
then
sorry I'm cold doing the brake thing
again okay I don't think you're going
the right way are you know you're not at
all
I hate this trace no you can go do the
miles I think now actually might as well
I guess yeah okay
where's moe make the most of it
[Music]
[Music]
no it's not you're whining so much three
was there was like a death episode where
you just the whole two hours afterwards
we spent trying to kill the nemesis or
just no just trying to escape him
remember how that game is not good I
don't
I love Resident Evil okay and I like
resonable three but two more hussain
thinks that's the best resin evil get
out of here everybody has their own
opinions but that's just wrong what
you're allowed to say that whatever
everyone's allowed to have their own
opinions that yours is wrong three sweet
okay wait wait where's the gold ring did
you get dropped it oh okay so leaving
that's like saying alien 3 is the best
Allen and I don't I like that movie more
than most people uh yeah I get the
suitcase okay that's on the others side
of the damn train did he cross this
train like so many times I do it on
purpose
these daisy dukes the only thing
carrying me
I thought daisy dukes for the boots I
think it's the shorts
they're typically worn with boots yeah
you're right
oh because it's named after named after
Daisy Duke from the people who drive the
car fast The Dukes of Hazzard Meredith
from that from that show about those
guys you drive too fast
wait now what go upstairs for the
suitcase
Joey pass it
go upstairs you mean in the middle train
either way you have to go that way no
good standing around stupid I eat this
train I said that's the only thing I
like those are cool it bothers me how
like low-res those stairs are compared
to the rest of the game oh [ __ ] oh this
is the wrong no it's your right I mean I
don't honestly know anymore no this is
the other room this is the wrong room
isn't it but you can go farther down the
hall I can push I keep coming toward the
camera so we were on the right place to
begin with but we went downstairs again
we haven't learned anything really hurry
up enough dumb dumb sounds like right
next to it I got it okay
wait that's not what I meant okay so I
want to
drop them all shatters and blows
everyone up oh my [ __ ] god
this room is too full nice move around
it's yeah leaving the hallway it's too
full or like people send the comments
you might just be shitty it might know
it might not be the room whose might
have to move a little bit so drop it
somewhere else
don't shoot those you I don't I don't
think they their ammo expenditure counts
what
that's abusable well they're not that
good I don't know I could be wrong that
could be wrong that that must be right
cuz otherwise like you would just have
to eat live leave them with the [ __ ]
knife all the time that's true
please pick up the right thing thank you
let's do this
give me that card okay so we're about to
do the big bazinga
right yeah all right so let me get these
items and convento
that the song yeah but I didn't ask for
a [ __ ] Julie
no not with that attitude you could save
right now
ah this a saving area
no but there's ink ribbons in the room
downstairs I mean I kind of want to
after the day we've had
yeah no you don't need those they're in
the room save romário you're right
okay so now what go downstairs Steve
okay we have a we have a thing him and I
Oh God
is there anything we should do before I
start this motion in action of the Train
save anything else no this the saver No
[Music]
No yes this way
right there save room or one of these is
the saber let's just do a different
resin you'll know I like this game a lot
another knife they've really
oh no he dropped those heads from
earlier
here she is
this is so sad
we could save the brake sequence right
now let's do it oh we're [ __ ] doing
it you're going all the way [ __ ] pisses
me off all right so
touchpad this cutscene
other side of that or some button
understood X this does not make any
sense
squares leaked and why did it
contaminate both the lab in the mansion
as well as a train almost three miles
away that's irrelevant we must make
there must be a way to skip the calmness
we did the first one completely remember
start far away are you from the nearest
yeah it was start start is the one
options whatever [ __ ] ps4 calls it
always bucking tradition those Sony
people
all right make sure he's all reloaded
and stocked up and [ __ ] get after it
you saved your your fine start we still
have to do that the math sequence again
okay Rebecca's gonna stay behind sure
make sure to get the card and manipulate
the control panel for the break then you
apply the break from here okay all right
start why give that [ __ ] for interest
okay one second
Henry let your head go and you need
space for the card I know probably
dropping that guy runs or shakes yeah
exchanger in what exchange them
[Music]
okay mm-hmm okay and then there's
there's some on the floor too that you
want well just get those just do it fast
I can't cuz I can't get the card then
that's fine then yeah but you could
exchange them to her again
it's weird
no stop
okay let's go I need to change guns
[Music]
shotguns good because you just push
people out of the way yeah they're gonna
die anyway you much ya just dodged money
okay sprint straight through here you
could probably dodge them all without
even shooting I think you're right
because they come from the sides I'm
just gonna do it now while I'm thinking
about it though but we run agreement
[ __ ]
indeed [ __ ] all right so this one I
have to be really sneaky just fast go
baby go Billy this is not a fast hill
that one wait why did it look up [ __ ] my
best yeah very funny it just don't get
hit again oh there's another one in this
room I think I know that was so shitty I
like looked up in the sky I'm on caution
I'm okay
you shotgun it's not very good one go
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I love it like this is the plan for them
to use brakes like the guy who made this
train was like okay if we got to hurry
up and brake
you got to run in the other side of
train and you gotta put in these codes
they reach to a certain number Canadian
yeah yeah it doesn't seem very dumb it's
like the reason just like how there's
booby traps and [ __ ] and Spencer mansion
to justify that by saying he was just
paranoid but either way all right do
some math [ __ ] yes
[ __ ]
okay so do you so when he's the number
seven that the number you like yes seven
all sevens and then four
yes finally I've engaged the control
device for the break over this part is
poor game design yeah actually I can
tell I think we both know okay same
thing 36 that seems like a small number
all it's got to be less than six right
through all threes and then for where
that makes sense we can no no no that
would be 26 yeah no all threes and then
let's do it
all threes times 9 27 7 no 9 9 yeah 27
36 need to get this do you wanna just
get ready to close on so I'll be her and
I don't remember who has more health but
I know where Billy is on caution okay
it's not shooting switch to him I don't
know if you want to worry about
switching this we did last time that's
how they got you
why didn't switch I thought I was her I
was [ __ ] dumb is what happened
oh yeah just move out of the way at the
very least
oh he's dead
well [ __ ] me is that all we had to do
think so it's probably another one no
yes he's just [ __ ] standing there and
egging them on I wonder if there's more
if you don't kill him on the train
either way that seemed like they're all
dead the shotgun also seemed much more
effective in his hands
cool God well let's go save damn it okay
so there here's all the items you got
first-aid good green herb good what's
that pucks [ __ ] knife or sorry hook
shot oh nice more pucks can I just see
something you really think that like
that doesn't affect how many shotgun
shells he has cuz he only has three left
I don't know maybe it did I think it did
I'm gonna look it up that's helpful to
know
they're both on caution
should I can I do you think I'll be able
to come back in here or what I can't
believe he [ __ ] died we could have
done this like I'm in a better state
this time but not mentally like I hope I
can come back to this room also just
interacting with an object and saying no
will show on the map I don't want to do
this
should I heal yeah like I definitely
don't want to do this part again you
know but like am I gonna use my green
and red herb ease spurt sucks
I guess we good
he's on orange so I don't mind using
green and red on her but she's only on
yellow so I'm only gonna I'm gonna eat
an herb for her pick this up stupid
she's on yellow she's on yellow
she's it gonna use no you know I can
always drop things later right I meant
just you when you picked it up you
didn't have to put him your inventory
then use you coulda just used it right
it's fine okay and then I was gonna have
him eat something too like this first
AIDS bread that's technically wasting
its potential cuz you're only at orange
I know but I think I have another one
because I was good and like see there's
like one right here okay you know I'm by
me there's gonna be a typewriter soon
yes okay and then we'll just go and
we'll use a typewriter and we'll forget
this day ever happened no well we were
gonna do a longish episode anyway it was
nine and a half so as of now yeah we
didn't something horrible could happen
Oh God hold on yeah let's let's inspect
what's back anything back sword that
dead-end good luck
[Laughter]
what's in her Daisy Duke just kind of
works she's going on here she's wearing
they didn't redo this cutscene she's
wearing a different outfit that's dr.
James Marcus she's just a rookie
[Music]
[Music]
are you it was I who scattered the
t-virus in the mansion needless to say I
contaminated the Train to what revenge
on umbrella ella ella
[Music]
Wow the leech master come to me my slimy
brethren
whoa just the leeches make a person ten
years ago dr. Marcus was murdered by
[Music]
okay Oh at the bottom of this I mean if
it means anything else like how rude
shotgun shells yeah there's a lot of
stuff in here let's do that next time
okay so no auto savings game that's all
so yeah we know that now yeah sweet well
it could have been worse well you are
shorten this set up wait hold on ignore
this intro for a second I want to bring
the lower thirds back up and not sure
how else to do this
why just so you know who we are oh yes
Mary are you trying to plug here youtube
again yeah yeah don't forget to Like and
subscribe
parties yeah we'll be back next week as
always well then I shouldn't say as
always has we been gone for two weeks
but welcome back I'm like I'm happy to
be back oh I'll be a pack as well [ __ ]
are you when do you leave we're both
doing the kind of funny thing when do
you leave Thursday the 31st we're
recording we have time so we do we're
gonna put up an episode during packs ok
I will see you guys then if you want to
watch us Oh actually will be competing
in that tournament kind of funny yes
people can come watch that kind of funny
pair Sneijder video game Cup tournament
extravaganza I'll actually be competing
against Mary so you can finally see how
much better I am at games
I don't know that's what you learn from
it yeah co-op I don't do good at these
games but well thanks for joining
I'm gonna I'm gonna go and good bite
subscribe to your channel and then
unsubscribe so that it says you lost